[Music]
sometimes it seems like Nandi State nags
just won't quit until they've banned
every last thing that looks good tastes
good or feels good they've targeted
bacon dogs smoking singing in bars bake
sales baggy pants in 14 states have
banned fish pedicures this is something
that's I think needs to be banned if
state senator Jeffrey Klein has his way
New York will be next on the bandwagon
now Mandy's in New York and nothing new
but what about New Hampshire you know
the Live Free or Die State fish pedicure
was banned by the state of New Hampshire
that's right the state that lets adults
ride without a helmet or drive without a
seat belt won't tolerate tiny fish
nibbling a dead skin I was very very sad
I was very disappointed Kim Ann's
parents brought her family from Vietnam
to America in 1985 they said this
country as a country of freedom a
country of opportunities um took that
message to heart and today she owns Kim
spa nails in Derry New Hampshire when
the recession hit she began looking for
new ways to generate business she
thought of fish pedicures the luxurious
practices popular in Asia and she
decided she would be the first to bring
it to New England it was a big
investment for for me she invested time
in researching making sure fish
pedicures were safe the last thing she
wanted to do was put her customers at
risk we do a lot of research believe me
we we talk to a lot of people she also
invested plenty of money $6,000 for the
fish and a water filtration system
investment was a big risk but it paid
off when she saw how customers reacted
at first it tickled a lot I was kind of
scared but once I got used to it it
really was a very fun experience word
spread and soon on had awaiting this for
this hip new service things are going
great until the New Hampshire Board of
barbering cosmetology and aesthetic
stepped in they feel that fish pedicure
is not sanitized for the consumer that's
why they abandoned us I didn't see that
it was a sanitation issue at all I knew
from being in the salon that that was
never a problem and so I thought that it
was
ludicrous at that point regulators
categorize these tiny fishes tools that
must be sanitized but you can't really
sanitize fish like other tools that is
unless you cook them but I mean if you
cook the fish they all die but if fish
pedicures are dangerous we want to know
Nick and I have been getting pedicures a
pedicure from fish after all reason TV
zone nickel SP got a fish pedicure on
john stossel's show I do want to point
out that the fish have nibbled off my
extra toes on each foot so very grateful
since then we've been secretly
monitoring Nick to see if he succumbs to
some horrible disease so far so good but
we wanted New Hampshire regulators to
tell us what kinds of awful afflictions
might be headed Nick's way we may never
know because state regulators said they
were unavailable for an interview but we
need to let people know where are these
sick people state senator Klein called
for a ban even though the state of New
York had not received any complaints
about fish pedicures here's Kline posing
outside a salon if there were angry
victims of fish pedicures you'd think
he'd get them to pose with him and if
there were victims in New Hampshire
why wouldn't regulators point to them to
make their case show me the person who's
been sick or injured or better yet show
me that it's a recurring problem and
then maybe there's a case for some
change dr. Adrian Moore is an economist
with Reason Foundation
he says regulators are often slow to
accept new innovations like fish
pedicures they're not using the newest
technology the way the innovators and
the entrepreneurs are they don't maybe
even understand it I just wish that they
each get themself more a little bit
instead of like you know just saying no
to me it's really the foxes guarding the
henhouse what does he mean well the
people who regulate hong's industry only
do that part-time most of them are salon
owners themselves that's right
unghh is regulated by her competitors if
you're in the business and in industry
you don't want new businesses bringing
new techniques that attract away your
customers this is going on all the time
Moore says most people have no idea how
highly regulated entrepreneurs are until
they try to start their own businesses
every day new businesses try to start
but find out that they're not allowed to
because of some regulation or it's too
expensive because of some regulation
very disappointing very disappointing
let's allow these new industries to
emerge and that's how we grow the
economy good advice especially during
the recession but isn't more at least a
little worried about what all that fish
nibbling might have done to Nick well no
they nibbled all over my body and I'm
still fine you see during a recent trip
to China more I went to a spa like this
where he enjoyed a full-body fish
nibbling but more is worried about the
nanny state and if that's spreading into
New Hampshire the one place we thought
had built up immunity to it we may all
be in bigger trouble than we thought for
reason TV I'm Ted balances
[Music]
[Music]